To illustrate learning by correcting mistakes,
let's go back to an earlier example.
We encountered this example when we were discussing explanation-based learning.
So imagine again that you have bought a robot from the Acme hardware store, and
in the morning, you told your robot, go get me a cup of coffee. Now the robot
already is bootstrapped with knowledge about the definition of the cup.
A cup is an object that is stable and enables drinking. The robot goes into your
kitchen and can't find a single clean cup. So it looks around.
This is a creative robot and it finds in the kitchen a number of other objects.
One particular object has this description. The object is light and it's made of
porcelain. It has decorations and it has concavity and a handle. And the bottom
of this object is flat. Now the robot decides to use this object as a cup,
because it can prove to itself that this object is an instance of a cup.
It does so, by constructing an explanation. The explanation is based on the fact
that the bottom is flat, that it has a handle, that the object is concave, and
that it is light. Let us do an exercise together that will illustrate the need
for learning by correcting mistakes. So shown here are six objects. And there're
two questions here. The first question is, which of these objects do you think
is a cup? Mark the button on the top left if you think that a particular object
is a cup. The second question deals with the definition of a cup that we had in
the previous screen. So mark the button on the right as solid, if you think that
that particular object meets the definition of the cup in the previous screen.